en la comisión hace cuatro años tantas
cosas han cambiado en el mundo para
nuestro país y para mi familia como
tantos estudiantes alrededor del mundo
yo me gradué de la escuela de leyes
durante la pandemia nuestra generación
está unida se enfrentando el futuro en
momentos inciertos y muchos de nosotros
estamos considerando qué tipo de país
queremos vivir como una recién graduada
puedo verme reflejada en muchos de
ustedes mi padre creó una gran economía
una vez y lo hará de nuevo créanme por
eso les pido a cada uno y les urjo a ir
más allá de las barreras políticas esta
es una lucha por la libertad en contra
de la opresión por la oportunidad en
contra de la estagnación una lucha por
mantener a eeuu verdadera a sí misma
hagamos un juicio en res pasados
resultados si creen en la reforma la
justicia penal solamente hay un
presidente que pasó el forester act
dándole a la gente una segunda
oportunidad en la vida una oportunidad
en la vida nuevamente y si creen en
expandir la salud asequible
solamente el presente champions mi padre
firmó otra acción para reducir los
precios de los medicamentos y evitar que
roben los estadounidenses la gente debe
reconocer que nuestros pensamientos
nuestras opiniones e incluso la elección
de por quién estamos votando están
siendo manipuladas y lo están haciendo
por los medios y los gigantes de la
tecnología si van a los medios en una
sola opinión parcializada y si lo que
crees no concuerda con la agenda que
ellos tienen entonces se ignora o se
dice que es una mentira esta
manipulación de lo de la información que
recibimos
impide nuestra libertad en lugar de
permitir a los estadounidenses formar
sus propias creencias esto mantiene a la
gente mentalmente esclavizada y esto es
un miedo y una división que no son
necesarias porque tanto en los medios en
el mundo de la tecnología e incluso
nuestro gobierno están tan comprometidos
con promover una visión parcializada a
las cosas pregúntenselo porque porque no
nos dejan ver cierta información porque
solamente se promueve un punto de vista
mientras se esconden los demás la
respuesta es control porque la división
y la controversia crean beneficios pero
cuáles son las consecuencias cuando
solamente un lado de la historia sale o
cuando solamente un punto de vista se
convierte en aceptable para nuestro
sistema educativo significa sacrificar
el debate civil creando una atmósfera de
los estudiantes con opiniones contrarias
no pueden hablar
y tratan de encajar y nuestra nación
sufre acabando con la diversidad de
pensamiento y la inclusión de ideas
trabajando por fuera de nuestra zona de
confort política va a cumplir mucho más
y algunos son políticos cínicos no
quieren creer en el milagro de eeuu pero
yo sí fue un máximo pero dijo la noche
si se pierde la libertad en este país no
hay ningún otro lugar a donde ir tener
esperanza no es una debilidad y creer en
los milagros es un regalo de dios
entonces esta noche quiero decirles la
verdad de en qué creemos nosotros
creemos en la equidad de la oportunidad
nosotros creemos en la libertad de
pensamiento y de expresión piensen lo
que quieran busquen la verdad aprendan
de otros con otras opiniones y hagan su
voz escuchada ante el mundo
creemos en la elección
escuelas porque el lugar donde vivía un
niño no debe determinar su futuro
creemos en la libertad de religión para
todas las fes y creemos en el espíritu
estadounidense un país fundado en ideas
no en identidades donde nuestras
diferencias son aceptadas y donde la
palabra sueño
es válida porque aquí
tu vida es tuya si estás escuchando esto
y estás pensando ese es el tipo de país
en el que quiero vivir bueno ya sea que
te hayas dado cuenta o no estás apoyando
a hecho quiero que veas más allá de la
fachada de los políticos si se hacen
pasar por decentes mientras tratan de
acabar con nuestras identidades y
creencias mi padre es la única persona
que ha retado al establecimiento
a la burocracia interna el mono de los
monopolios de los medios y a las
farmacéuticas para
para asegurarse que las verdades
constitucionales se mantengan y él no la
escapa un reto incluso ante el odio
porque luchar por eeuu es algo por lo
cual él va a sacrificar cualquier cosa
que él sueña en grande para este país y
él irá con todo para alcanzarlo entonces
eeuu grande de nuevo no es un eslogan
para mi padre es lo que lo impulsa para
mantener su promesa de hacer lo correcto
para los ciudadanos estadounidenses
la energía del cambio y la oportunidad
está con nosotros dios nos ha bendecido
con un espíritu que no se puede parar el
espíritu estadounidense mi padre ha
probado de estar impulsado por ese
espíritu él ha demostrado su fe y en su
corazón y también con sus acciones mi
padre me ha hecho creer que estados
unidos realmente puede ser grande de
nuevo si te importa vivir tu vida sin
restricciones
sin tener que rebelarse contra aquellos
que tratan de oprimir la entonces la
elección es clara un voto por mi padre
es un voto para mantener y defender
nuestros ideales estadounidenses y
mantenernos verdaderos a estas
realidades estadounidenses muchas
gracias y que dios los bendiga